with world number two fabian caruana
fabi uh this position was definitely
enterprising looks like you prepared it
and then became that critical moment
where you chose e5 and as yesterday was
asking instead of f5
why did you opt out of this move did you
look at f5 and why did you opt out of
that and it said play the ultra sharp e5
yeah i wanted to play f5 and then i got
attracted to this e5 idea
um
and i'm kind of shocked that so bad
although now that i think about it it is
incredibly anti-positional move but i
thought the tactics would work out for
me uh and and they don't
and i i mean there's multiple multiple
problems which
shows how far off the mark i was
um
okay ripped you one i was worried about
after rookie six
but i didn't realize it was so bad
and uh and rook d1
didn't
cross my mind
but rook g1 did worry me i expected this
move and i was very surprised when he
took
on d6 um
what was your rook d1 you said you
didn't see and rick d1 uh the engine
gives is just windy yeah yeah
i saw the computer just so i was like i
resigned
um
which wouldn't have been great
were you or where was his birthday by
the way peppy yeah
so you're so you saw f5 but you felt
like e5 was just sharper and and may
work
because yeah no f5 i thought would be
about equal because um he is in time to
get queen b2
um
this
square protects all his pawns and then
rook f8 he can play rook g on rook f6
king h1 put the rig on g2
and
we'll probably hit an impasse at some
point
um like rook g6 i can even trade rooks
and
i think
yeah
i mean at some point i probably want to
trade rooks with rook g6 and uh
and we're going to reach
yeah i guess a roughly equal position
because
white doesn't really have ways to make
progress because his pawns are so bad
his king is weak he's up a pawn but
he can't do anything and and i also
can't do anything because i mainly just
have a blockade i don't really have um
have ways to improve the position but
yeah black black is certainly quite
comfortable
um so you weren't satisfied that's what
it was
i don't even know how to explain my
thought process yeah
and what was your intention against rook
g1 the move you had seen yeah i i only
realized after i played this that rook
h6 king f1 is probably quite bad
it was
this is where realization
is so i was going to play de5
um
g1 yeah
i was looking at like bishop e4 here
and knight f6 and
it didn't look like
a disaster
um
and okay i glanced at the computer
briefly after the game and it said queen
c2 which
um
looks strange to me doesn't attack
anything
but i guess it prepares king h1 and rook
g2
after which
i opened white's bishop on a1 which was
his real real bad piece exactly um
so if he consolidates then he is
significantly better right
well thanks for for joining us just one
last thought
you've played four rounds you played a
very nice game yesterday first two
rounds didn't go so great for you and
today again
it seems like just some hiccups what's
uh going on
yeah i can consider myself pretty
fortunate overall from the positions i
had in this tournament i think i
extracted the absolute maximum
i couldn't have gotten any more points
um i could have easily
uh scored minus two in this tournament
from the positions i had
uh so yeah i was pretty lucky so far
i mean e5 is a terrible move i i don't
i'm kind of
ashamed i played it i don't really know
how to explain it
all right well thanks for joining us and
uh right the ship a quick question for
you patty out of the opening uh you
played a move i'm a very inspired move i
like it a lot b7 b5 uh explain your
familiarity with it was it something
that you saw from a player or did the
chess engine when you were prepping uh
this move
where where
did you first discover it
i discovered it over the board today
but you've seen it you're familiar with
it i didn't
i didn't
know this move b4 okay and then
it looked the thing is actually it is
kind of interesting um okay
after bishop a1 b5
um
i mean i can play b6 but okay that's
that's a normal position i think white
is a tiny tiny bit better yeah so b5 was
more
uh i will try to just equalize
without
um without playing a long protect
protracted game and then i actually
thought he would play
bishop d3 like he did
in the game
yeah because if bishop b2 then my bishop
goes to d7 and i actually collect the b5
pawn
um
i thought that i equalized very
comfortably there bishop d7 knight bd5
and
and i have various ways to round up this
pawn
and bishop d3 i thought uh wesley is a
genius he's going to play bishop b7
bishop e2
i was worried about this
and
okay i didn't think that i would really
be worse here but i thought it was very
clever to provoke my bishop to b7 where
it can't attack his pawn
and if he gets like a few moose castle
bishop tour okay one then he's a clean
pawn up
but i thought i had a few ways to uh get
to disturb his plans right um but then
he allowed me to take off three i
thought okay
black should be completely fine thank
you
i was very familiar with this plan of b7
b5 because of the great uh vishwanathan
dan he had played it against me in a
blitz match we had in
manila i have to have to admit i didn't
know this
it was a private match
but thank you good luck and well
get back into
the form that got you the number two
place in the world
yes
whoo he's dodging some bullets as our
fabby is